- Welcome everyone to the main event panel
featuring the three hottest writers
in the fantasy sci-fi biz.
Let's hear it for 'em.
(crowd cheers)
(bird caw cheering)
Do you mind sir?
Thank you.
Okay first question, what new
characters are you working on?
We'll start with you Greg R.
R. H. L. L. L. Q. T. Harkin.
- She is an exquisitely
beautiful ballerina
and a deadly assassin.
It's Vendetta Veets.
(crowd cheers)
- Well how bout you Kim
Ber Lee of Vernel Comics.
- Falcon Man is finally
getting a sidekick.
Falcon Boy.
(crowd cheers)
(victorious music)
- But if there's anyone
that's gonna top it
it is the comic book genius
himself, John Queebon.
John.
- Yeah, what?
- What new characters are you working on?
- So many to choose from.
- Tell us 'em all, yes.
(clapping)
- Doctor Detangler.
He's really good at detangling earbuds.
(crowd claps weakly)
- [Host] Kay, okay nice.
- Or there's the human paper shredder.
He eats paper and then a few
hours later he expels it.
Not to mention the Garbage Bag Guru.
When he gets a new garbage bag, he always
knows exactly which side has the opening.
Right, you know cause like
it has the little the thing.
(knocks glass over)
- [Voiceover] Comic book writers
aren't themselves when they're hungry.
- We doin' autographs now or later?